[Música]
salud tendría hecho américa de france 24
me acompaña en el estudio más romeros a
la mar bienvenida buena mañana del lunes
vamos a iniciar con la organización
mundial de la salud que finalmente
decidió no categorizar la vida del mono
con una emergencia internacional buenos
días raúl buen lunes efectivamente es
una decisión que llevábamos esperando
desde la semana pasada se reunieron el
jueves y este comité que se llama comité
de emergencias de las regulaciones
internacionales de la salud recomendó a
la organización mundial de la salud pues
no dar este nivel de alarma que es por
ahora por ejemplo han merecido pues
pandemias como el comité hizo nueve o la
crisis del ébola se consideró que no
estamos en ese lugar todavía pero
igualmente hubo algunas advertencias de
escuchemos lo
el comité observó que muchos aspectos
del brote actual son inusuales como la
ocurrencia de casos en países donde la
circulación del virus de la viruela del
mono no se había documentado algunos
miembros sugirieron que dado el bajo
nivel de inmunización contra la
infección de la viruela hay riesgo de
transmisión sostenida entre una
población más amplia el comité también
resaltó que la actividad del virus de la
viruela del mono ha sido en el líquido
durante años en países de la región
africana márquez recomendaciones recibió
la ms pues básicamente mantener la
alerta y sobre todo monitorear algunos
factores no lo que se desprendía también
del comunicado es que el comité se
volverá a reunir y volverá a evaluar una
serie de factores como por ejemplo la
velocidad a la que habrán crecido los
casos y ha aumentado mucho si por
ejemplo los contagios se han extendido
muchos más países que la transmisión
también además llega a grupos
vulnerables como las personas
embarazadas o inmunocomprometidas
recordemos que por ahora este brote se
ha cobrado la vida de una persona que
precisamente a una persona pues
inmunocomprometidas también o que
aumente las severidad de la enfermedad
que se descubre alguna variante del
virus más virulento también o más grave
o más transmisible todos estos factores
haría reconsiderar tanto al comité como
la organización mundial de la salud este
nivel de alerta que por ahora no llega a
ser una alarma global igualmente pues
eso seguir atentos a cómo avanza y por
supuesto a esa advertencia que leíamos
también no que es ese riesgo de
transmisión sostenida porque recordemos
que la gente dejó de vacunarse contra la
viruela cuando se radicó esta enfermedad
entonces hay una capa de población que
está alrededor de los que estamos por
debajo de los 30 años o 35 que ya no han
recibido esa vacuna y que podrían estar
con un poquito más susceptibles a la
enfermedad claro mar ahora vamos a
hablar de otro tema precisamente para
digamos de alguna manera hacer un
preámbulo a nuestra segunda mitad del
día nuestro tema del día vamos a hablar
de eeuu y la prohibición del derecho al
aborto que podemos decir de eso es una
perspectiva más de salud pública si es
inevitable no tocar este tema estamos
hablando de salud reproductiva de las
mujeres entonces vamos a vamos a hacer
un breve también inciso una explicación
aquí primero recordar que la
organización mundial de la salud
contempla el derecho al aborto como una
forma de preservar la vida y la salud de
las mujeres luego también que la misma
ms y múltiples asociaciones médicas por
ejemplo la revista the lancet se han
opuesto a esta decisión de la corte
suprema de estadounidense recordando que
prohibir el aborto no hace que
desaparezcan sino que se vuelvan
clandestinos y que por lo tanto sean
menos seguros repasemos las cifras por
ejemplo de que implica qué consecuencias
tienen estos abortos inseguros no en
eeuu sino en todo el mundo se calcula
que hay alrededor de unos 73 millones de
abortos anuales en general y que casi la
mitad de ellos casi el 50% son abortos
que no están hechos en condiciones
seguras que no tienen garantías de
seguridad y también se calcula que estos
abortos inseguros provocan las muertes
maternas entre 47 perdón y 13,2 por
ciento de las muertes maternas también
sin necesidad de llegar a la muerte se
calcula que provocan en la
hospitalización de unos 7 millones de
mujeres por estos procedimientos
recordemos además brevemente que hay dos
tipos de abortos
ecológico y el quirúrgico el
farmacológico suele ser un poquito más
seguro y se usa
la píldora en edades tempranas pero que
igual necesita acompañamiento médico y
una de las cosas que se temen que pueda
suceder con la prohibición del aborto es
que si alguien necesita atención médica
pues no la vaya a buscar por miedo a ser
criminalizada por otra parte el
quirúrgicos consiste en extraer el
efecto y hay un método es hemos aceptado
que es como una especie de succión
podríamos decirlo así pero la mayoría de
abortos clandestinos otra usan otra
técnica que es el legrado y eso que es
como raspar las paredes del útero es lo
que tienen más riesgo la mayoría de
abortos clandestinos así provocar pues
pueden provocar hemorragias daños en
órganos internos o infecciones y término
beneficio impactante si vamos a
brevemente a otro tema sólo una cifra
también pensando en la cumbre del g7 que
está sucediendo actualmente recordemos
que todos estos países del g7 son los
países más uno de los países más ricos
del mundo se comprometieron a entregar
una serie de vacunas contra él como 19
para los países en vías de desarrollo
2.100 millones particularmente
han cumplido la mitad de ese objetivo y
según oxfam esas vacunas podrían haber
salvado hasta la fecha de hoy 600 mil
vidas en estos países en desarrollo marc
como siempre muchísimas gracias por toda
la información de salud en directo
américa de francés en 4 mañana por
supuesto nos vemos con más de nuestra
sección pasamos a saludar a nuestra
segunda invitada del día